(dramatic adventure music)
- The 2010s was the decade
of the superhero movie.
We saw the first three phases
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe along
with a bunch of onscreen
appearances of heroes
from DC, the X-Men, and even Pixar.
Here are the top moments and
scenes from superhero movies
in the last decade.
- Just leave her alone and
everything will be fine.
- The anti superhero film
"Kick-Ass" helped usher in
the decade of the superhero.
The movie is probably
remembered for this scene
where the 11 year old Hit
Girl takes out an entire room
of henchmen.
- Meenie, miney, mo.
- The R rated superhero flick
didn't start and stop there.
- Oh, oh hello.
- 2016's "Deadpool" was
an envelope pushing smash.
- (beep) Did I leave the stove on?
- The movie's opening car
chase truly exemplifies
the spirit of the film
where you have Deadpool
just breaking the fourth
wall to talk to the audience
while taking out the bad guys.
(Deadpool groans)
- Rich Corinthian leather.
- Ugh.
- We'll say Ryan Reynold's
third attempt at being
in a superhero movie went a lot better.
- Stop or we will shoot.
- Freeze him Charles.
- I can't.
- [Cop] Hands up!
- The X-Men prequels
started off really strong
early in the decade and then
ended on a disastrous note.
Let's just cherish this
shoot in Quicksilver time,
which is one of the
coolest slow motion shots
since "The Matrix's" bullet time.
(adventurous music)
(bad guys groan)
The super fun sequel
rightly teamed up Scott Lang
and Hope Van Dyne.
The movie's most memorable
scene comes when The Wasp
has to fend for herself in the kitchen.
Meat tenderizers are flying at her,
she has to shrink and
grow and deal with all
these other related kitchen objects.
And it's really a chance for
Evangeline Lilly to shine.
(knives fly)
(soaring uplifting music)
Marvel waited way too
long to make it's first
female superhero movie.
11 years into the MCU the
studio delivered Captain Marvel
and gave us this scene showing
everybody why Carol Danvers
is the most powerful hero in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Carol is being held by
the Supreme Intelligence,
rips out her power dampener
and delivers this line.
- I've been fighting with
one arm tied behind my back,
but what happens when,
(electricity crackles)
I'm finally set free.
- Then she fully powers
up into her binary form
and we see just how powerful
Captain Marvel really is.
(spooky music)
For Guardians we could've
gone with Groot dancing
or even Quill dancing, but
sometimes a memorable moment,
it's not even about the characters.
Take this scene where
the Guardians fly into
the lawless Nowhere and David
Bowie's "Moonage Daydream"
is blasting on the soundtrack.
♪ Freak out in a moonage
daydream oh yeah ♪
Not only is it full of
awesome establishing shots
further building out Marvel's
galactic onscreen presence,
but unknown to us at the
time, it also sets up
the location of a pivotal
scene from "Infinity War".
Freak out,
far out,
indeed.
(soaring mystical music)
- [Mera] Welcome home.
- Speaking of sweeping
landscapes, how about the first
glimpse of Atlantis in "Aquaman."
Who could've thought the
Atlantis of the comics
could be brought to life so vividly.
Just watch the giant
tortoises and whales flying
over your head and let
your imagination run wild.
Bonus points to this movie
for including a few things
constantly mocked about
Aquaman and making them
kind of awesome.
- Okay now I can turn invisible.
Selecting a bagel.
Act super normal.
- Spiderman?
- You know that's funny, I get that a lot.
- Spiderman had a very weird decade.
He was portrayed by multiple actors
and was the subject of
a massive fight between
two rival studios.
This was one of the
high points of Spiderman
on the big screen.
In fact "Into the Spider-Verse"
even picked up the Oscar
for best animated film.
Wanna know why this movie got that Oscar?
Just take a look at this stunning scene
where Peter B. Parker and Miles Morales
are swinging through the woods.
Miles is finally starting to get the hang
of the web slinging.
- Okay, thwip and release.
Thwip and release.
Thwip
- And release.
- You're a natural.
Thwip
- Release!
- It's one of the many
moments where this movie feels
like a comic book come to life.
And speaking of animated superheros
(raccoon growling)
(fighting sounds)
Fans waited 14 years
between "The Incredibles"
and "The Incredibles 2".
That first movie ended with a tease
of baby Jack Jack's powers,
emphasis on powers, plural.
In the sequel, Jack
Jack's powers went berserk
when he went head to head with a raccoon.
He was zapping it, smacking it,
even tried to set it on fire.
Really makes me wish Pixar would get
into the superhero business full time.
(inspiring music)
Marvel's on screen
battles have just gotten
better and better as time has gone on.
This battle for Asgard
on the Rainbow Bridge
is set to Led Zepplin's
"Immigrant Song" making it
the perfect combination
of song and fight scene.
And when the song gets to
"Valhalla, I am coming"
♪ Valhalla, I am coming ♪
("Immigrant Song" continues)
Valkyrie, long associated with
Valhalla in Norse mythology,
is swaggering across the
bridge to enter the fight.
And Thor's other allies,
Loki, Hulk, Korg, Heimdall,
and the rest of Asgard
are all doing their part
to take Hela and her forces down.
With a brand new director,
"Thor Ragnarok" was
a breakthrough moment for the
character on the big screen
giving him much more
humor than he had before.
- You're late.
- You're missing an eye.
- At the end of this movie,
Cap wakes up in what he thinks
is the 1940's only to discover
that he's been frozen for 70 years.
He's eventually met by Nick Fury.
The twist was executed well
and the movie also ended
with one of the most heartbreaking lines
in any superhero movie.
- Yeah, I just, I had a date.
- Steve Rodgers would finally
get that date with Peggy in Endgame.
And speaking of twists
- Don't hurt the face.
I'm an actor.
- In "Iron Man 3", The Mandarin,
who we're led to believe
is the main villain, is
nothing more than an actor.
- Just a role, The
Mandarin, see it's not real.
- It's a clever twist, but also
one of the MCU's most divisive moments.
This never actually happened in the comics
and if you we're a fan of them,
you we're kind of deprived
of the chance to see
Iron Man face off against
one of his oldest foes.
Me, I feel like Marvel didn't
have a whole lot of options.
It was the studios fix for a character
who was developed around a whole lot
of racist tropes and stereotypes.
- At least you talk.
Who are you?
- It doesn't matter who we are.
- "The Dark Night Rises"
was gonna have a tough time
toping 2008's "The Dark Night",
but it came pretty close in
this thrilling opening scene,
which introduced us to Tom Hardy's Bane.
It's an unforgettable opening,
not just because they
filmed it in real planes
and also not because all of your friends
had terrible Bane impressions
after this movie came out.
- No one cared who I was
til I put on the mask.
- The script says do a Bane voice but
(muffled) mines really bad.
(laughs)
(muffled) I was born in the dark.
(laughs) I can't do one.
(intense music)
Wonder Woman makes her grand entrance,
a bright spot in an other
wise awful movie and a sign,
not fully realized at
the time, that there was
a brighter future ahead for
the DC Extended Universe.
Just try to get that theme
music out of your head.
(Intense theme music)
We're gonna come back to
Wonder Woman in a little bit.
- Before we get started,
does anyone want to get out?
(fighting)
(alarm)
- Now, this is among the
absolute best fight scenes
in the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
and it's not on a giant battlefield.
It's just Captain America,
a bunch of Hydra soldiers,
and a very cramped elevator.
This scene was so memorable,
that it showed up again in "Endgame".
(rock music)
This was by far the best of
the solo Wolverine movies.
It was the dark and emotional portrayal
that the character always deserved.
I could choose any action
sequence from this movie
that gave it it's R-rating,
but Logan's death, really
felt like everything
was coming full circle, and it
was truly the end of an era.
- Don't be what they made you.
- Logan's entire life has been a battle
and he can finally be at peace.
Now give us an X-23 movie already.
- Where is this one from?
- The Bobo Ashanti tribe
from present-day Ghana, 19th century.
- "Black Panther" was
a groundbreaking moment
in pop culture.
It's Best Picture nomination
can attest to that,
but it's not the movies
hero I want to talk about.
It's the villain,
Killmonger, and his intro.
- How do you think your
ancestors got these?
You think they paid a fare price?
Or did they take it like
they took everything else?
- Perhaps you're already thinking
"Hey is it even fair to
call this guy the villain?"
- But I see through you.
(whooshing)
- "Doctor Strange" expanded the MCU
far beyond normal fighting.
Nowhere is that more apparent than when
Doctor Strange first meets The Ancient One
and she takes him on quite the trip.
- [The Ancient One] What
mysteries lie beyond
the reach of your senses.
- The visuals feel like a callback to
the original Steve Ditko
creations from the 60's
and it set up a lot of what was to come
with reality bending and time
travel later on in the MCU.
(grunting)
- Mysterio takes Spiderman
through a mind bending trip
through a whole bunch of projections.
It's mesmerizing and terrifying.
Just look at zombie Tony Stark.
This already feels like a sequence fans
will be talking about for a very long time
and other Spiderman movies,
both animated and live action,
are gonna have a hard time topping it.
The third Captain America
movie isn't just about Cap.
During a pivotal battle
at an airport in Berlin,
the Avengers found themselves divided.
On one side, we had Iron
Man joined by Spiderman,
Black Panther, and War Machine.
And on the other, we had Captain America,
with Falcon, Winter
Soldier, and Giant Man.
Scarlet Witch made cars
fly through the air,
Ant Man grew to the size of a skyscraper,
and Spiderman made "Star Wars" jokes.
- Hey guys!
You ever see that really old
movie, "Empire Strikes Back"?
- Jesus, Tony.
How old is this guy?
- I don't know, I didn't carbon-date him.
- This made watching the team fall apart
completely worth it.
(dramatically intense music)
DC got ahead of the MCU with
this female led superhero film.
Set during the first World War,
includes this thrilling
scene set in No Man's Land
where Diana marches across the battlefield
drawing all the enemy fire
so the soldiers can advance.
If this sequence doesn't
make you a Wonder Woman fan,
nothing could.
So, we've hit the top 3 and, yes,
it's just going to be the
Avengers movies here on out.
When you think of superhero films
from the last decade or so,
this is probably the first
image that comes to mind.
(Hulk yelling)
(Avengers theme playing)
At that point, we'd
been waiting four years
since the first Iron Man movie to see
the core Avengers all
together in one shot,
suited up and ready for action.
And this image is just straight up iconic.
It's rare to see a superhero
movie end on such a downer,
but the snap in "Infinity
War" proved to be
the "Empire Strikes
Back" of Avengers movies.
And we we're left to
wonder for an entire year
how those heroes would come back.
Because the movies make way too much money
to not bring them back.
(Avengers theme plays)
This was the hardest movie
to pick a scene from,
so we're gonna cheat and
say the entire third act
because technically it's the
ending to 21 other movies
and it delivered.
You have Thor, Cap, and Iron Man
coming together for one last stand.
A throwback to the first Avengers movie
when they first came together
and fought over Loki.
And if you saw this in theaters,
you really thought one of
them was gonna die here.
But no, the Russo's
decided to instead deliver
on more than a decade
of teases and build ups.
Cap shows he's worthy by wielding Mjolnir
and summoning the lightning.
He straps on his shield for what he thinks
will be the last time and
Sam gives us a callback
to Winter Soldier to let Cap
know the cavalry has arrived.
- [Sam] On your left.
- Don't say it, don't you say it.
- On your left.
- Come on!
- It looks like all of Wakanda is there.
All the wizards are there.
Valkyrie has shown up on her pegasus.
Even Pepper Potts is
there in the Rescue Suit.
And Captain America delivers
the iconic battle cry
that fans have been waiting years to hear.
- Avengers!
Assemble.
- They could have just left it at that.
But nope the battle still
gave us some great moments.
Tony and Pepper fight back to back.
Tony finally hugs Peter.
There's the gauntlet relay.
All the female Avengers come together.
If you saw this in theaters,
especially opening weekend,
then you know how much
the audience cheered
for each and every one of those moments.
And how dusty the theater
got for Tony's funeral.
That ending is why I
paid to see this movie
in theaters three times.
- [Producer] You saw it
three times in theaters?
- You didn't?
Did we miss any of your favorites?
Let us know in the comments.
- [Captain America] That is America's ass.